good morning sherry three big traffic
stories the first
is kind of over as you mentioned in the
southwest that three alarm fire
did completely close fort apache between
trop and russell road for several hours
it is back open
that gives us a chance to move over to
the east and to the south with a
reminder of our continuing coverage of
that three alarm fire
here we go northbound on the i-15 before
silverado ranch
all lanes were blocked just a moment ago
nhp still blocking the left the center
and the next to the center you're only
getting through on the right and the
right shoulder once again this is
northbound on i-15
coming up on silverado ranch it's going
to be a substantial delay for you
but there's still more we're going to go
up to the far northwest looks like
they've made some progress and maybe
fixing to get you back onto the south 95
at durango but
a big rig overturned about 11 30 last
night it looks like it is back on its
wheels now after
three giant tow trucks but for you you
still have a no go on to the 95 from
durango
for alternates we're suggesting get over
to fort apache or buffalo you could go
up to skycam to get onto the 95
or go down to the 215 beltway that'll
get you under the 95 as well